what's the purpose of dialogue in story
I think it really develops character and
I think how someone talks is part of who
they are um so for me coming from
theater that was always how I found the
story and found characters and I would
start with dialogue and just put two
characters in a room and and have them
talk and figure out who they are and
what's their Dynamic and what are they
interested in and what do they do all
day and um so I
think it really dialogue really helps me
find the story and then you know of
course you have to go in and structure
it and and trim it and and do that all
in the rewrite but but I like the
characters to tell me what the story is
why do you love dialogue I love to just
let the characters take me places
um I think when when I'm really writing
well I'm just sort
of guiding it but letting them kind of
take it and then I'll have certain
things that I want to do but I'm not too
heavy-handed with where the story is
going and so that's what I love about it
is when the the characters surprised me
with dialogue and I write something that
I didn't think I was going to
write that's really what I love about it
do you think East Coast stories are
heavily dialogue driven I mean there's
there's a lot being said H I never
thought about it um I think just because
I come from there yeah maybe I I didn't
really think of it as East Coast or West
Coast but but yeah I think I I think
also just growing up in the theater and
coming from theater you know there's so
much more dialogue in plays uh as
opposed to scream place so I think
coming from that place uh and now moving
into more film and TV uh I think my
stuff is all very dialogue driven and
character driven but at the same time I
know you said you like uh show don't
tell yeah so so if you had to make a
choice between some witty dialogue
versus just showing a character that's
always the the struggle right it's like
but I love this conversation they have
yeah but is it moving the story forward
and can you do that in a more cinematic
visual way I think that's always what I
have to remind myself and have to
relearn all the time because sometimes
I'll fall in love with my dialogue but
it's not really whooping the story
forward um so yeah you're constantly
fighting that battle and learning that
lesson I hate that term killing Your
Darlings but you know I think it's true
it's true you have to at some point you
know not fall in love with your your
words when you think of great dialogue
what comes to
mind I mean I love KY Wan uh you can
count on me it's one of my favorite
movies uh I think he writes great
dialogue
um yeah I
I TR Noah bomback love his dialogue uh
so I think yeah those were the the the
two filmmakers that I feel like most
influence me in terms of like writing
dialogue um and also just plays
playwrights um Tennessee Williams you
said yeah I love Tennessee Williams uh
his dialogue is like so poetic and and
beautiful it's it's um there's also a
great playwright uh named Jonathan Mark
Sherman who I he was doing plays um with
malapart which is a theater company that
he and Ethan Hawk had together and uh
that was really influential seeing his
plays when I first came to New York um
because it's like sometimes Tennesse
Williams can be intimidating you know if
you're a young writer and you're I mean
it's inspiring but it's also like so far
from you so coming and seeing somebody
like Jonathan Mark Sherman and you know
he was also acting in a play with my dad
so I got a chance to meet him and talk
to him and and uh and realize like oh I
could do something like that you know so
I think sometimes uh having more of a
close connection is even more
inspiring did you say you ran into him
around town or well he's uh he's also an
actor uh he acted back in the you know
early 2000s when I was in New York and
and he and my dad were doing a play
together and that's how I ended up
seeing a play of his called veins and
thumbtacks which is a hilarious uh play
that malapart uh
produced I think in the early 2000s um
but that seeing that play really was one
of The Inspirations for me to write so
yeah what has writing stage plays taught
you about
dialogue um that there's a rhythm to it
and there's uh it's almost like there's
a musicality to it uh that I
think he could almost like close your
eyes and and listen to a play um and
still get the story it's not as uh as
visual as film so it's you're kind of
telling the story through dialogue and I
mean obviously things are happening in a
play and there's behavior and everything
else but it's more Central to the
storytelling than in a film do you think
you could turn most films into a stage
play no no I don't think so how about
Manchester by the sea is there a way to
well he's a playwright so yeah I think
Ken Lan stuff really kind of goes back
and forth like something like Lobby hero
you could see that as a film and you
know I think with playwrights it's
different but I I always have a hard
time with when it goes the other way
when you take a play and try to make a
film of it because I
think they never expanded enough and it
always just feels like a play that
they're filming you know so I think you
have to kind of reimagine it because
they're just such different mediums for
storytelling how can dialogue enhance or
destroy
narrative um well I know a problem that
I have a lot coming from theater is too
much dialogue I think that can sort of
slow The Narrative down and again make
sure it's moving the story forward you
know rather than just falling in love
with like oh I love this dialogue I love
this scene but if it's not moving the
story forward then yeah the narrative
can kind of fall apart um but it
enhances it you
know lyrically and and if it's poetic
dialogue and there's Beauty in it and
you know it can really uh Elevate uh so
it's not just pictures you're looking at
you know there's a there's a poetry and
a music Al ity to dialogue that can
really enhance things well some people
are Masters at it you know Aaron sorin
Woody Allen yeah heavily you know
dialogue driven films right yeah but I
guess not everyone can pull it off and
maybe if they do it's trying too
hard yeah yeah I think a lot of times
it's derivative or you feel like they're
imitating but I think if it's if it's
like you know one of those guys that
really knows how to do it uh there's
real Masters at it you know but it's in
the end it's like all storytelling right
so it's like yeah if the dialogue's
enhancing the storytelling and it's
compelling then then we'll be into it
but I think sometimes it can sort
of weigh it down if it's too much
dialogue how do you differentiate the
voices in your
stories
H I don't know I just let them talk
and the characters
will kind of take you places and um
they'll have different
voices I don't feel like I'm giving them
I'm going to make this character working
class and this character you know I mean
sometimes you can do a little of that
but but I think if you're
listening um the characters will
surprise you and they'll have their own
voices um but that's really the the work
of it is to get to that place where you
can really listen to your characters and
and they'll tell you what they want to
say and uh that's the magic of it and
the fun of
it so when you've listened in a crowded
uh establishment yeah can you get a
feeling of who these these characters
are based on this short Snippets of
conversation I can yeah and I mean I
love like taking that little snippet of
conversation and then like but I don't
really know who those people are I don't
know what they do or where they're going
to go after this Diner and so it's like
a a little inspiration of reality and
then I get into my imagination and I
create the character and I create the
voice and I do all that stuff um but I
love that sort of you know it comes back
to truth is best served through fiction
you know it's like I'm not going to
follow those guys all day and write down
everything they say but if they say
something that inspires something in me
and Sparks my imagination then that's
exciting and and fun what causes
dialogue to go
flat
um again if they're not if they're not
propelling the story I think if you're
just kind of talking in circles and
nothing's happening between the
characters um or sometimes dialogue can
be you know people know how write really
clever witty dialogue but there's
nothing going on between the characters
and it's not moving the story forward I
think that's what can cause it to fall
flat is there a scene of a movie that
you can think of that's where there's
just like this sort of very simple
dialogue but the way it's said is so
beautiful that it's resonated with you
it's stayed with
you um I mean the classics are like
Casablanca you know um which I I watched
we were talking about that Warner
Brothers dock earlier I found out in
that that they shot two endings to that
where um you know they end up together
in one of the endings and then you know
which would have totally ruined that
movie um but yeah something like this is
the start of a beautiful friendship you
know that comes to mind
um yeah you know I talked about Kenny
Lawry and his dialogue and you can count
up me and Manchester by the Sea the
scene with um Casey Affleck and Michelle
Williams so it was like beautifully
written and constructed and yeah there's
just Masters at it that that can really
um create something something beautiful
do you think television has same type of
dialogue or is it sped
up does it there's not enough breath in
it because we have act breaks and things
yeah I think I mean depending on the
television I mean something like flea
bag like I love the dialogue and that
you know but um but yeah it's a it's a
different kind of writing depending on
what the show is um I mean nowadays the
bear and and stuff like that it is sort
of similar to to screenwriting in that
way um so the lines are kind of blurred
between film and television depending on
what you're you're
writing